Mathieu bonsoir déjà
tu sais que je t'aime beaucoup mais
c'est vrai que l'année dernière
les liens d'amitié qu'on avait tissé
petit à petit il a pris fil c'était
largement enfin beaucoup distendu
chacun certainement ses responsabilités
mais du coup comme je faisais pas TPMP
j'étais tous les soirs devant mon poste
et un soir j'ai pris en pleine face que
ta déception de l'année c'était moi
voilà alors que tu étais mon meilleur
ami et que tu te plaignais que je te
voilà que je t'appelle pas assez que je
te vois moins et tu supputais que notre
amitié que je croyais sincère et
peut-être seulement une amitié de
plateau et pas une amitié sincère
ça m'a énormément vexé parce qu'on va
vexer blessé parce que si tu avais
quelque chose à me dire tu pouvais me le
dire en face à face tu pouvais m'appeler
voilà on est quand même suffisamment
même si les liens c'était distendu on
pouvait quand même se contacter
s'appeler on s'appelait régulièrement tu
me l'avais jamais dit même si on le
pensait certainement chacun de son côté
on s'était jamais formellement exprimé
et tu le balance comme ça l'antenne sans
que je puisse te répondre donc du coup
bah tout le monde a dû penser que voilà
j'étais un peut-être nul etc mais c'est
pas très c'est pas tellement ça le
problème c'est plutôt que voilà j'étais
blessé que du coup tu passes par tes
besoins de passer par l'antenne pour
dire tes ressentiments envers moi alors
là où tu avais raison c'est que c'est
vrai que les liens c'était distendu
entre nous
et j'ai certainement mes torts et tu me
connais suffisamment pour savoir que
quand je suis un peu
dans quand je suis je suis pas très bien
j'ai tendance un peu à me renfermer sur
moi-même à pas dire pas dire vraiment ce
qui va pas etc et c'est vrai que je me
suis un peu recroquevillé chez moi et
mon chien sans boire beaucoup de monde
etc et même mes meilleurs amis je les
voyais pas beaucoup
mais voilà j'aurais préféré qu'on en
parle directement et tu savais très bien
surtout que mais si je m'étais
recroquevillée c'est aussi parce que je
traversais même si je me plains pas du
tout de ma situation mais je traversais
une situation financière
délicate de mon propre fait voilà je des
des impôts me sont tombés dessus etc je
me plains pas du tout c'est que j'aurais
dû payer en heure en temps et en heure
je l'ai pas fait du coup il y a un
rattrapage ce qui est tout à fait normal
mais comme je travaillais moins du coup
bah la situation a été plus tendue pour
moi
et ce qu'on attend d'un ami évidemment
dans ces moments là c'est que un peu qui
vous soutiennent même si c'est pas pour
m'aider en tout cas qui me cherche à me
trouver des solutions pour que je m'en
sorte
et je t'avouerai que
Benjamin par exemple que je voyais que
je voyais beaucoup moins que toi et qui
lui passe des
traverses une situation financière bien
plus difficile que moi évidemment 1000
fois plus difficile par exemple m'a
proposé de m'aider j'ai refusé il m'a
dit si tu veux je te prête de l'argent
alors qu'il en a pas et je me suis dit
quelque part
et Mathieu qui lui vit bien parce qu'il
travaille beaucoup et ça je respecte
complètement voilà et ben il m'offre pas
de solution et en plus ils mettent pas
ils mettent pas le au minimum pour m'en
sortir parce qu'il y a des mois où
j'étais vraiment
semblent du tout les Français qui vivent
des situations bien plus difficiles
évidemment mais il y a des mois où
j'étais je vivais avec 5 6 euros je
mangeais que des pâtes etc je me plains
pas du tout c'est de ma faute
intégralement
et voilà et du coup on en est resté là
et les seules fois on se voyait c'était
pour jouer au poker parce qu'on a tous
les deux cette passion du poker et il se
trouve que dans la chance tu as une
chatte de ouf et tu gagnais à chaque
fois poker avec moi et du coup tu
participes à graver ma dette donc du
coup c'est non seulement j'avais pas
d'argent mais quand je te voyais en plus
tu participes à creuser mon trou
financier et à chaque fois qu'on se
quittait tu me l'aura appelé on m'ont
envoyé un texto en disant on est bien
d'accord que ma tante adepte s'élève à
temps et je me suis dit mais c'est quoi
c'est ce meilleur ami qui m'envoie un
texto après pour me dire par écrit que
je dois t'en alors que c'est pas
d'autres pourraient m'aider ou me dire
genre voilà je vais t'aider en trouvant
une solution n'importe quoi pas
forcément en donnant de l'argent mais
dans un peu je savais pas voulu parce
que le poker c'est le poker j'ai CAPA
jouer donc voilà j'ai perdu j'ai perdu
c'est pas un souci mais tu me l'as pas
tu m'as pas réclamé
verbalement l'argent tu me le disais pas
mais à chaque fois qu'on se voyait tu me
disais tu oublies pas et à chaque fois
du coup ça mettait une pression et du
coup c'est vrai que j'avais de moins en
moins envie de te voir besoin de te voir
parce que je me disais à chaque fois je
vais le voir il va me rappeler que je
perds l'argent j'avais déjà des
créanciers autour de moi je vois pas mon
meilleur ami Pour qui me dise on
t'appelle et creuse un peu plus la tombe
donc voilà l'un dans l'autre c'est vrai
que les liens se sont distendus mais je
le regrette parce que tu sais très bien
qu'avec toi on passait des moments
fantastique c'est-à-dire de complicité
de ouf c'est-à-dire qu'on se raconte nos
vies nos amours nos peines nos ambitions
on regardait des matchs pas les matchs
de foot et en tout cas les Grands Prix
de Formule 1 etc ont passé des vrais
moments ensemble et ces moments là ce
sont petit à petit évaporés
et je le regrette comme je pense que tu
le regrettes aussi parce que on était
très très proche et moi j'aimerais bien
qu'on retrouve cette cette proximité là
envers l'autre et pour ça évidemment je
voudrais que tu fasses ma date ma date
de poker voilà alors déjà cette élève à
combien Jean-Michel
je sais que le Duplex je sais que vous
êtes assez loin Jean-Michel
je sais pas exactement mais je pense que
c'est aux alentours je pense de 2000
euros quelque part
mais la dette c'est pas le plus
important la dette je veux bien
m'engager à le rembourser s'il arrête de
m'en parler voilà moi le plus important
c'est qu'on se revoit quand on se
retrouve comme avant voilà sans qui est
de cette pression financière et que
évidemment je m'engage à le rembourser
mais c'est pas mon une créancier
principal évidemment j'ai les impôts
j'ai mon logeur etc mais dès que je
pourrais le rembourserai mais qu'on se
voit sans parler de ça OK
Jean-Michel nous a expliqué toute
l'affaire il a été voilà il a été très
précis Mathieu
alors ma question est simple Jean-Michel
t'a parlé déjà avant de nous dire si tu
ouvres le rideau ou pas est-ce que tu
voudrais dire quelque chose sur tout ce
que tu as dit Jean-Michel pas ça très
dur très dur et très triste qui m'a dit
parce que je crois qu'il le sait assez à
quel point pardon ça reste une grosse
somme mais je me foute ces 2000 euros
mais d'une force sans nom et je pense
d'ailleurs que je n'ai jamais pensé les
revoir je m'en fiche complètement
c'était faut tout dire mais c'est juste
que c'est vrai que quand je faisais des
PNP toutes une fois par semaine j'avais
dîner chez lui en joue au poker mais
c'était un prétexte on dîner tous les
deux
enfin voilà quand j'avais pas bien aussi
je dormais chez lui il y avait son chien
qui était là enfin on avait on a une
vraie vraie vraie complicité c'est vrai
et j'ignorais totalement Carnières il y
a des problèmes d'argent et c'est vrai
que quand j'ai quitté l'émission j'ai
plus de nouvelles de lui dans les
semaines qu'on suivit et puis un jour ça
c'est quand ce que je vais vous dire
mais c'est un jour il me dit là on est
vraiment Pascal qui vit chez moi pendant
trois semaines il fait du théâtre je me
suis dit en vrai Jean-Michel c'est un
ami de TPMP en passant notre camp en
fait j'ai quitté la bande et bah il a
trouvé Jean-Pascal et puis c'est
éventuellement Rachid arabe
et c'est vrai que du coup on s'est moins
vu et puis il parle pas beaucoup donc il
raconte pas ses soucis Jean-Michel et
voilà on s'est moins vu on savait enfin
je savais pas du tout qu'il allait ses
problèmes d'argent enfin il sait très
bien que
j'ai pas proposé parce que je savais pas
mais que contrairement à Benjamin si je
lui ai proposé j'aurais pu lui donner
mais
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a proposé de l'argent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà on s'est moins vu pendant cette
année où j'étais pas là moi comme
j'étais pas là et que je voyais plus je
me suis dit en fait voilà ce qui est la
bande de TPMP parce que c'est un peu
compliqué de quitter la bande aussi
c'était du covid tu es tout seul chez
toi tout ça ben voilà et puis on était
vraiment très très proche avec Jean-Mi
très très bon je crois que c'est pas
c'est les 2000 euros c'est c'est
lui pour Jean-Michel pardon oui c'est ça
reste un gros somme
voilà
c'est que qu'il vous soyez plus aussi
proches les un jean
j'ai envie que vous m'entendez j'entends
mal mais tu vois Jean-Mi même
dernièrement là quand depuis que je suis
revenu je lui ai dit évidemment ça te
dit ça te dit qu'on dîne ensemble il me
dit oui comme ça et puis il y a plus de
nouvelles il y a plus de suite j'essaie
de raccrocher les wagons j'ai envie de
plus de 3 mois et tu as pu le voir je te
dis ça te dit que je passe ouais passe
un weekend puis tu relances jamais j'ai
l'impression de t'ennuyer je te sens un
petit peu triste aussi en ce moment et
je sais pas comment gérer le truc parce
qu'on a pas 14 ans alors sans doute que
je suis maladroit mais tu veux tu as
bien vu tu as vu j'ai essayé pour te
dire la vérité comme ça on peut tout
dire j'ai envoyé un texto aujourd'hui à
Cyril c'est vrai ou pas et qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que je t'ai mis dedans je t'ai
mis est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que
Jean-Michel peux faire TPMP people cette
semaine exactement c'est vrai voilà
parce que tu le faisais plus et que j'ai
très envie que tu sois dans l'émission
pas que pour l'argent encore une fois
mais pour voilà pour accrocher les
wagons que tu sois dans la bande parce
que je trouve que tu amènes beaucoup
font que tu es hyper intelligent et je
lui ai envoyé ce texto là aujourd'hui
Cyril m'a répondu bien sûr ça m'a touché
enfin voilà peut-être que je suis
maladroit mais ce que je sais c'est que
pour terminer un soir j'étais chez lui
ça fait gamin ce que je vous dis mais il
m'a dit voilà ça fait deux trois ans
qu'on se voit on s'entend très bien tu
es mon meilleur ami moi c'est des mots
qui sont forts j'étais son meilleur ami
et puis quand je quitte l'émission je le
vois plus alors voilà ça fait un peu
gamin tout ça mais j'ai l'impression que
vous avez tous les deux le même problème
en fait j'étais très peiné j'étais très
peiné ouais après je pense qu'on est
deux de personnes enfin
assez seul finalement on passait
beaucoup de temps ensemble et du coup
dès qu'on nous abandonne un peu on est
en panique et puis vous savez comment
c'est les amitiés si vous laissez un
tout petit peu de temps passé vous
sortez du quotidien vous avez plus grand
chose à vous dire si vous savez à quel
point ça me fait mal quand je le croise
dans les couloirs là et qu'on se dit
salut salut tu l'as vu ça tu es salut
salut ça va il sort du 6 à 7 je me dis
ça va et donc de fois je disais Valérie
mais c'est horrible c'était mon meilleur
ami on s'est dit salut ça va ça va il y
a pas la phrase d'après on a plus rien à
se dire
salut salut ça va ça va
il y a une chanson de Patrick Bruel non
mais salut ça va
ça va merci vous regardez ces yeux je
pense que c'est le garçon le plus gentil
que je connaisse quand sur Isabelle sur
n'importe quoi on avait dit ensemble il
me disait faut que j'envoie un texto à
Isabelle je vais être sûr que je l'ai
pas vexé le plus gentil que je connaisse
je trouve qu'en ce moment j'ai envie
d'aller un petit peu triste et
j'aimerais bien voilà effectivement je
suis sûr que ça peut ça peut redémarrer
il faut c'est pas encore de la Formule 1
tous les dimanches ensemble il adore ça
je crois le refiler la passion
maintenant on peut aller au Formule 1
et évidemment que si ça ça sera hors
caméra mais si je dois t'aider mais mais
c'est évidemment c'est Jean-Mi qu'est-ce
que tu as demandé à Mathieu aujourd'hui
concrètement non j'ai surtout lui dire
que je suis désolé si je l'ai blessé en
étant moins présent que cetera mais il
me connaît suffisamment pour savoir que
quand je suis pas très bien je voilà
j'ai tendance à m'isoler un peu je
pensais qu'il le savait et je pensais
pas qu'il leur sont il avait un
ressentiment au point de le dire comme
ça la télévision mais que si ça vous
blesser je m'en excuse mais c'est très
bien que je l'ai dit à la télé c'était
un peu c'était un peu brutal dans
l'émission parce que je pense que tu me
connais Cyril aussi et que il y a pas de
filtre je suis tout le temps à fond à
zéro et je dis beaucoup de conneries et
des choses voilà mais c'est toujours
vrai et peut-être que je l'ai fait
effectivement pour faire bouger un petit
peu les choses je pense que j'espérais
intérieurement que tu regardes aussi un
peu l'émission parce que j'osais pas le
petit texto ou parce que je voyais que
ça reprenait pas et d'ailleurs je sais
pas si ça t'avait touché ou pas parce
que j'avais pas de nouvelles mais mais
vraiment j'espère parce que j'en suis
pas sûr que ça peut démarrer ou que vous
êtes vous êtes tous les deux très
mignons parce que j'ai l'impression que
vous avez tous les deux envie de la même
chose c'est-à-dire pour retrouver
repasser des moments ensemble retrouver
cette amitié qui a fait que vous étiez
les meilleurs amis tous les deux
et c'est vrai que
je pense que tu sens mis comme Mathieu
vous n'avez pas retrouvé
l'équivalent ni pour toi Mathieu ni pour
toi j'ai envie d'un mature
même si même si Benjamin a pris beaucoup
de place depuis parce que il a été très
présent aussi mais j'en passe beaucoup
de lui mais c'est un gamin mais qui a le
coeur sur la main on l'adore et je me
suis beaucoup rapproché le benjamin mais
j'ai un cœur suffisamment gros pour
accueillir de de meilleurs potes et
Benjamin voilà profitez-en
[Rires]
et on est encore temps
on en reparlera
ultérieurement
de Jean-Mi non et puis tu sais quand tu
as une amitié très forte avec quelqu'un
si elle descend un tout petit peu comme
un zizi non mais il y a quelque chose
tout est remis en cause mais j'adorerais
parce que c'est un garçon exceptionnel
parce qu'il m'apprenait beaucoup parce
qu'il est cultivé parce qu'il est gentil
parce qu'il est gel enfin voilà
j'aimerais beaucoup laisser un garçon
assez seul en vrai et
voilà j'ai un texto d'ailleurs de qui de
Garou qui me dit celui qui n'a jamais
été seul au moins une fois dans sa vie
Mathieu accepte tu
as du tutu chapeau pointu
d'ouvrir le rideau
dans la vraie émission
ouvrir le rideau
Mathieu je vais te le reposer plus
sérieusement Mathieu
Mathieu
[Rires]
accepte tu
touches à pourquoi tu dois dans ton cul
d'ouvrir le rideau
les amitiés sont rares je veux conserver
celle-là oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà c'est ça que j'aime c'est ça que
j'aime
bon je suis heureux de vous j'espère que
vous allez vous retrouver tous les deux
après je peux pas passer par toutes les
émotions toutes les émissions c'est pas
danser m'énerver Jean-Mi Jean-Mi il est
mûr c'est vraiment un amour de mec il
faudrait dire Jean-Mi c'est mon c'est
mon frérot d'amour il le sait non mais
il y a quelque chose aussi c'est vrai
que je l'ai eu parce qu'il y a quelque
chose d'un peu honteux d'être dans les
difficultés qu'on gagne bien sa vie
parce que c'est vrai qu'on gagne pas
beaucoup qu'on ait des enfants qu'on
travaille comme des bêtes et qu'on n'a
pas beaucoup d'argent quelque part c'est
normal mais c'est dur mais on sait
pourquoi alors que quand on gagne
beaucoup d'argent comme j'en ai gagné et
qu'on n'est pas bien bah c'est c'est
quelque part c'est qu'on a mal géré que
c'est quelque chose qui est pas normal
et c'est honteux donc du coup on s'en
ouvre peut-être moins et du coup on
garde plus pour soi
non parce que j'ai pas envie d'emmerder
les autres
[Applaudissements]
je rigole
pas
Jean-Mi bon il faut que vous allez vous
retrouver tous et bien sûr évidemment
mais on est les liens se sont un peu mis
un peu en flouté mais ils existent
toujours donc il suffit de régler de
m'acheter
mais on a toujours autant de plaisir à
se voir mais on se voit moins mais voilà
c'est j'ai ma parole est-ce que vous
voulez que je fasse est-ce que vous
voulez que je fasse un truc pour vous
est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
envoie voir le prochain Grand Prix c'est
quoi le prochain Grand Prix
dernier Grand Prix en mer après
tu peux regarder s'il te plaît tout de
suite c'est faire regarde hop je vais
dans accepter non c'est loin calendrier
alors un calendrier
[Applaudissements]
Singapour c'est non japonais
du quartier